Coffee on the Tuesday and blog eight.
Right.
So Halloween was yesterday and the
weekend was a whole lot of fun.
My friends had a lot of cool costumes to
it.
I love that.
You know,
I have friends who put a lot of work
into it because just makes the holiday
fucking awesome.
I'm actually going to put these down
because it's a little bit dangerous to
have adamantium near a computer screen.
So before we get to the main event,
this luggage,
when I mentioned for a moment what I did
last night for actual Halloween,
I actually got the chance to see one of
my heroes last night in concert,
the author Neil Gaiman at the theater
on.
We'll show you haven't read anything by
Neil Gaiman.
Start doing that right now and if you
ever get the chance to hear him read
live in concert,
just buy the ticket.
Don't even think about it.
Performed with his wife,
Amanda Palmer of the Dresden dolls.
I never was too much interim music,
but to hear her live a was breathtaking.
After the show,
they came up to sign autographs and by
some weird turn of luck they just
started the line right where we were
standing,
so I got a chance to shake meals hand
and just extend my thanks for
everything.
Unfortunately,
I don't have any video that.
Oh wait a second.
Ah,
proof just goes to show how many times I
wear a pair of jeans.
Okay.
Let's get to the main event of this
blog,
which my friends do a web series and
sketch comedy shorts called the Burns
Worth Saturdays,
so in honor of Halloween they did a
short film called Pten.
Larry go to the haunted hotel and rented
out a room at the beautiful Langham
Hotel in Pasadena and film there for
about 12 hours.
About a week ago was primarily my
friends Steven's project and I helped
out as much as I could do.
I wanted to film some behind the scenes
footage that I could put it on this blog
and show you what it's like to make a
film over a full day.
Without any further ado,
here it is.
The making of Pete and Larry at the
haunted hotel.
What are we do?
What are you doing?
I want it to be static.
I mean,
what are you doing right now?
Nothing.
Get that fucking cocaine that you guys
should both freeze frame,
like not an actual person,
but you guys are just not moving and I'm
going to stop.
So yeah,
like I kind of punch you out.
I finish up my pine tonight.
I'm just standing there like this and
see if it goes.
Oh hell Larry.
Alright.
We'll see what they have on the door.
Bit looked so sloppy.
I really think that if it's.
If we look at the same time,
that's the only way it's gonna work.
What seems to be a serious problem?
You got a major problem was that it's
filthy in here.
My brother is having a conference,
the keynote speaker at the [inaudible]
conference,
so I suggested come in,
come in to me like we're hugging.
They put it in the eight.
So where are we in the filming of the
movie yet?
The second set of day I watched,
I watched the dark night again,
thinking you guys are insane because
it's just on a whole nother level.
Even with Heath Ledger,
it's just a whole nother level of moving
from that navigant.
You're saying that you think we're
insane thing that that begins is better
than dark night?
Absolutely.
When the truth is found to be lies.
Wow.
That's all I got for that.
Woo Woo.
Oh,
cool.
Good shots.
It's just one single family.
There's a lot more than covering that's
happening in the shots that the problem
is.
This whole scene just keeps going.
Action.
No one look at me.
Oh,
from what?
No,
somebody else.
Yeah,
it's too bad.
Well,
that's something where it's needed.
God.
Larry King of haunted hotel,
which is what we're filming right now.
Indeed.
Our.
And you just turn your head gear head on
top of mind.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Yeah.
That sounds fair enough.
Yet what's wrong?
So there you go.
That's about 12 hours of film,
a condensed into four minutes.
Check
for the link of that short film and the
rest of the Saturdays in the dubliner.
I also want to say that I'm really proud
of my friend Steven and all my friends
were continuing to make things.
You know,
they want to do it for a living,
but I think it's important that
everybody does that.
Everybody makes things,
whether it be a comedy short,
a dramatic show,
a painting,
a book,
a song,
Nsx sculpture or dance,
a show what as important that no matter
who you are,
no matter what you do for a living,
that you take some time to make
something that has no other purpose
besides itself.
It's important to tell about our souls
so that when people watch the things we
make or read the things we make or
listen to,
the things we make,
they can know who we are.